all right you can say the easter bunny  has some generous helpers right here in  the valley yes today organizers with the  lvmpd foundation picking up thousands of  baskets plastics eggs toys candy water  they bought for metro officers to hand  out in local neighborhoods and the goal  of course is to build that trust between  law enforcement and the community  these events allow our officers not only  to show that officers  do good things  to these children but also helps to  uplift these communities because many of  them wouldn't have easter baskets if it  weren't for the police department  this year there are enough goodies for  about 7 000 kids a record for the  foundation